let's have a look at the seat abde abde
and a CFG on two squares or two sides of
any triangle ABC aah is perpendicular to
BC so a H is the altitude and beats BC
at H which is actually in the origin now
in the diagram below a reference system
has been set up and a sequence of steps
intended intended to prove the three
straight lines DC f bah-bah concurrent
so basically what they've done is you
know you've got all this coordinate
information on there right but if you
think about it without the coordinates
ok just draw any triangle your life he's
a triangle ok and if you make two
squares out of any of the other sides
like this
how's that that's pretty scary right
it's saying that if you join now let's
have a look which which ones that we got
here if you join up this lion here or
here to here and from here to here it
ought to be concurrent with the attitude
us what you said right that would be the
attitude there okay now what they've
done is they've set up all of these
quarters to help us prove that okay so
in some ways they're kind of giving us a
big help it can but it's still not an
easy question even then you get given
all these hints but that's the idea
we're trying to prove that's the concept
all right now I should probably include
that yeah I think DC
and you get many that's imaginative
isn't it I think it's anyway so they
make tweakin curve with the altitude
okay concurrent that means was that mean
they're all going through one point yeah
so not to confuse you come in here which
is at points at all okay so these are
clients aa point alright Part A says
what's the shape and size of the
triangle has been chosen two squares
should be determined show that the
coordinates of D coordinates of D are
should be through B minus a B minus a
minus B okay and then I think plug B is
just reversing exactly the same idea but
at this point over here sure how would
you do it now a couple of people will
read on this that's fine just looking at
it right now what kinds of approaches
could you take to work out or actually
got to work out to show that these are
coordinates of this point what ways
could you do it it takes us
so DB this right angle yeah okay yeah
and then what ah good okay sure I can
find an equation for this line an
equation for this line
I suppose I could solve for their point
of intersection that would work
equations isn't important with one of
the approaches that's going to be a
little trickier because I'm going to
need two equations of two lines but I
don't know what this point is yes I've
got to find that right yes I'm going to
use that background I don't know that
yet I have to prove that I can't use the
result for improvement and the same
problem goes Abe I told you know where
he is I mean I can watch check it out
but you can't prove that quickly to use
that as a result however just as an
honor on a good point okay Dean passes
through this line so if I can get its
equation that'll help me out I can do
something with that so it's a but is
there any other different ways we can do
it any other geometric properties that
we could take
it's wins right she's got a lot of equal
signs any other way this is three marks
okay so when looking at this shape right
and because you've got squares which
have equal sides
right you've also got all these
90-degree angles all right which means
you've got a whole lot of other angles
to equal to each other so I shouldn't be
able to use congruence sankar right okay
so I think there's two beta version
unless you both of them they're never
mind anyway it's okay in some ways this
is a year eight question all the stuff
I'm going to show you like great yet
distance you all Aversa you ready but
actually pretty to begin on what that is
this is a lot of special needs in and it
can confuse some people so let's give it
a go which way should we do first let's
see just as weak as he mentioned it
first which was two up final equation
this line then we'll we'll go off that
okay so let me get rid of this we want
to find line line BD
how will we find its equation what
information do we have about live big
okay so I've got a coordinate that's
good
what else am I going to need to define
the equation of the line apart from one
coordinate okay I can either go the
other point but that's that's the bottom
option because I need to find that so
that's the good
alternatively I can use the gradient
okay so I'm going to use this form okay
now I've already got my x1 and y1 there
right there okay
what's the grade of this life how would
I go about finding it okay sure I had it
the gradient of this line because I know
what those two twins are so that's
defining this line is based off of that
one just perpendicular okay so let's go
through the steps I'm gonna come back to
this in a second right I guess I can use
this space down here let's work out the
green ear baby what's the gradient
what do you think
yeah yeah get in Jim
are we happy
does that look about right Naomi is the
great employee but I get if it's
positive right so is this right
no wake up people
I say look it looks pretty positive
doesn't it but it's not why not yeah so
be sneaky isn't it lowercase B lowercase
B is a negative number isn't it because
on the left of the axis right so I
suppose forgot to blame the question in
some ways for setting up a million done
but I'm making a loop positive but we
also ought to have paid attention that
way so riders on the road really want to
be a minus B or watch out yeah
so yeah that's right B is negative B is
negative so if I just had a on be no
negative x or anything like that
I've got positive divided by negative so
that's a daily radio but that doesn't
look very negative to me it's increasing
alright so in order to make it pause it
I think you can you can go through and
do the full steps if we didn't deep
lines overrun you would have noticed
that rise let's go and then you do run
which is zero minus B so you would have
spotted it that way if you hadn't taken
trucks well it being that you load this
four-wheeler in here right and you are
in here eleven now at the end of year 11
I think you ought to be able to do those
two steps in your head why well in a
three my question where you've got way
more steps than mister like this is just
a building block okay so there is the
greater of that okay so now I want to
work out BDD right so I can say
therefore the great MapReduce is
no I can't use these because I'm trying
to prove them right so I don't know that
deception true yeah this should be like
my final lines so I can't use it in any
of my work in here all right so now by
the way I probably it would be nice as
well if I provided some justification
for where I plug this at the arrow from
maybe that meaning in a B are
perpendicular I can get so now I've got
my point and I've got my gradient let's
that's pop it in and we'll get the
equation of this line so the Y - let's
see if that's gonna be zero be on a x
there's nothing there's not that's
really there that could be okay now what
I do with this
I've got an equation so what
yeah
you mean you mean this because I don't I
don't know that it's you know it's it's
true yet number one I don't know is true
number two this this line right it goes
it goes on forever so there's a whole
bunch of points that satisfy that
equation which I'm not D right so just
because I can put these coordinates here
and it works for this equation means it
could be anywhere along this line not
necessarily this point in the square so
it would work that's like I hope it
works but that's not gonna be nearly
sufficient to prove yeah okay so before
before we actually do this why is this a
good idea
say it again just okay I'm not
necessarily gonna go all the way there
but just as on something why why is this
is a being any useful tool
why should I use it
right okay so number one uses the
properties of the question that it's a
square right number two this property is
very intimately connected to the actual
distance that I'm kind of work out right
actually sorry I'd love to read out this
distance try we get that point but that
distance at the point of opening okay
all right let's just work out the
distance first and then let's think
about how we're going to use this okay
so